Hey guys, How it going?
Welcome, to my office.
This is a virtual reality office tour
And I am so excited, because I've wanted to do one of these for so long.
But this one is super special because guess what?
You guys can follow me, you can follow me this way
And gonna take you on a virtual tour of my office
So I basically spend almost all of my time here
If I'm not out shooting or vlogging or traveling
So we'll start I guess over here, this is my mac editing station
So this is my Mac monitor which is connected to one of the trash can Macs behind there.
This is a nice stack of hard drives
Great for traveling!
This is where I keep a bunch of dongles, a bunch of cords
This is my little amiibo
My two favorite, Timmy and Tommy
This is one of my bigger vlogging cameras, this is the ADD by Canon
This is my every day G7 X vlogging camera
Which I feel like most vloggers do have
And most importantly as an unboxer, you've gotta have a good unboxing knife
So this is my, uh, very very sharp batman, unboxing knife
So as we cruise over here, this is the new Macbook with touch bar
Which I just recently got and I am obsessed with it. I think I'm eventually going to completely get rid off the trash can Mac
Get a really cool monitor for this and really just make this my home
if it isn't already
We've got this here that I use for doing vio
A lot of times I'll do vio in this room
But it is super spacious
And you can tell that it could be a little bit echoey as we move
But this alleviates a lot of that
This is a nice little razor mic that I use over here
These I put on top of my vlogging cameras as you could see over here
This is one
Each one I use for something different
Depending upon the situation
My prized possession is down here
This is a Nintendo 64. It's not even hooked up, but it just reminds me of a time in my life where *sigh*
I first really discovered my love of video games
Although, I did have a Nintendo entertainment system, the NES
Which I'm gonna bring you over here really quick.
This is the little NES mini! It's the classic edition.
So you can play 30 old school games
That is also one of my prized possessions
But as I bring you guys over here
This is my, I guess we can call this, the PC gaming station
I do a lot of live streaming over here and when I'm doing live streams,
I like to use this camera
And this is my PC
This is also another prized possession
This is my custom pink with my gamer tag, my xbox gamer tag on there
Ah so beautiful!
As you can see here, this is my VSVR headset, which is great
Because we're doing a VR video right now, so it's quiet appropriate
You might be wondering, what these speakers are for. Well if you spin yourself around directly over there I have a DJ set
So when that's actually hooked up, these are the speakers that go to that, more about that in a minute
This is my chair, I like to sit in my chair when I'm doing my work
Here are my consoles, I've got the Xbox One S down here
This is the new PS4 Pro, which is incredible
And as we spin around, this is where the magic happens
I got a nice microphone here and I'll spare you all the details but, basically everything plugs into here
Plugs in back here and then plugs into my computer
MAGIC!
This is also my razor laptop which I travel with when I want to travel and game
Love it!
Google Home, I just got this little guy, so I'm about to set this up here
So look for that unboxing and set up very very soon
And of course my Star Wars lamps which are on both sides
The best part about all of these lights is they're completely customizable
Using, walk this way,
These light bulbs, these are the hue the Philips lights  which I've showed you guys many times before
But they basically can control all of these lights just using an app
And right here, you might be wondering why I have an iPad Pro sitting here
I actually use my iPad Pro quite a lot when I'm using cameras that don't have flip-out screens
So I'm able to monitor the video and see what's happening
This is the DJ set, which I'm currently learning to DJ because my dog is a DJ
And he's coming out with an album
I know, it sounds crazy but, he's got some really great beats
So I look forward to showing you guys that
And maybe you'll come see us on tour
So last but not least, this is the unboxing table
This is where all the unboxing magic happens
So this is the camera that I usually use for the downward angle
This is Canon Cinema C100 Mark II
And this here is also another camera that I like to use as well
This is the Sony a7S Mark II
I use this a lot, you guys might have seen that
This one fell in the pool when I was in Hawaii and
it was an extremely devastating time of my life, but we've replaced it
We moved on and here we are
So this, my friends, is my office tour. I've also got some lights up here
The LED light panels which are incredible
So this is it!
My apple watch is going off too
Got my "subscribe" pillows which you guys should do
Subscribe!!
Ok, Bye!